l'aj auxerre à guy roux guyancourt à gi
bronch un même prénom pour une passion
identique du football entre guy brochot
et le sg histoire d'amour dure depuis
1946 jeu le plus beau d'ailleurs alors
âgée de 11 ans le jeune liancourtois
découvre le ballon rond moi je n'ai
jamais appris à jouer au foot on a
appris par nous mêmes on a les pointures
sur deux fautes déjà on jouait des
galoches à bout carré
vous n'avez pas connu à cette époque il
n'y a pas assez de joueurs pour
constituer une équipe à onze dans une
seule catégorie le stade popieluszko de
guyancourt et le terrain de ses premiers
exploits où il commence au poste de
gardien de but avant de passer défenseur
central et il paraîtrait même qu'il y
possède son arbre personnels lorsqu'ils
se marient à 29 ans vivent sacrifie sa
passion pour sa vie de famille moi je
veux pas car est non parce que tout ce
quart est après prennent une brioche is
ova je trouve que c'est vrai que tu t'es
trop jacques vont arrêter avant de
manger j'avais le soir ensemble parce
que le lundi avait réunion le mardi les
entraînements le mercredi c'est lé petit
le jeudi les entraînements des fois
mangé le vendredi soir en forme
guy brochot a eu tous les costumes à
guyancourt joueurs entraîneurs bénévoles
ici en bleu aux côtés de l'équipe senior
puis dirigeant en 1972 il participe à la
création du marâtre à une alliance des
équipes jeunes venus de tous à quentin
en yvelines
le sous sol de la maison faisait alors
office de laverie du club
j'avais tout un un placard avec les
catégories seniors le dimanche matin les
joueurs venaient en entre 10h et 11h
chercher le maillot
le doyen a aussi vu son sport tant aimé
évoluer
j'apprécie ce plus le système de jeu
mais ce que j'apprécie pas c'est de la
coopération des joueurs ils ont tous
deux
de distraction autres voiliers nous on
arrivait comme je leur disais les
garrots vous arrivez au vestiaire vous
accrochez vos habits et en même temps
vous a coûté vos soucis et vous comment
dire à eelv aux mauvais résultats à
l'école au club tous les enfants
connaissent guy l'entraînement commence
seulement après avoir salué l'ancien je
pense que dans chaque club
sont attachés à des valeurs une tribune
va bientôt voir le jour au stade maurice
baquet le club continue de grandir il
continuera un jour sans guy brochot mais
la relation entre l'homme et le sg
restera à jamais une histoire d'amour
pleine de fidélité et d'humilité